part of my own personal mission is to
break the idea that women should be
anything why you should be an
entrepreneur you should be a mother at
the end of day it really is what do you
want to be I'm trying to throw stone in
the ocean and creative tsunami keep
asking yourself questions well why do
you believe that why is that true is
that really what you want and in the
questions come your answers failure can
be the best freak'n lesson ever
there he is Lisa bill you in the house
how you doing
if you don't know Lisa co-founder of
impact theory she has her own YouTube
channel as well called women of impact
which I love I love that we're
showcasing more women entrepreneurs and
I want to talk to you today about women
entrepreneurship so one of the biggest
fights you get into with my team is that
we don't profile enough women on the
channel okay so every time we're doing
like a mashup video or top ten rules
video it's mostly guys and and when
we're doing like a billionaire mashup
okay we don't happen there aren't as
many women billionaires to start with
but on all the other videos I think we
need to put a woman in there when we
fight constantly a challenge is there's
just not enough content there's just not
enough women stepping up and making
content so we you know there's there's
you there's marie forleo there's no
Robbins and then it like pretty quickly
falls off or if you look to the guys
it's just so much more right why is that
that's amazing and god that's a really
good question I'm working every day to
figure out how we fix that and I think
the thing right now is you know women
are now stepping into owning who they
are and it's only really been a recent
thing you know so even take my own
history of creating you know co-founder
quest nutrition and that took me you
know 10 years to actually finally step
into that role and then evolved as a
person and then step out of it and say
okay this is who I am
so when you think about as the
discussion gets more and more now about
women stepping into their own I can see
in a year and two years and five years
and ten years it starts to be like you
won't be asking that question and part
of my own personal mission is to break
the idea that women should be anything
right you should be an entrepreneur you
should be a mother at the end of day it
really is what do you want to be and so
for the women that are finally saying oh
I will be in business I want to be an
entrepreneur now they're stepping into
it and maybe it's just like now that
just stepping into on step one so again
like in a couple of years you start to
see I hopefully more more women allowing
themselves to step into whatever well
they actually desire versus the role
that their history or their parents or
you know the culture has put upon them
so it's this really exciting time what
were you a Star Trek fan or are you a
Star Trek thing I'm not okay do you know
where this is going
yeah just inspire defies you know
lieutenant Uhura no okay so the original
Star Trek is Captain Kirk and in Spock
okay and then lieutenant Uhura so he was
learning command of the of the hip aim
at the time it was crazy that that a
black woman would be encouraged of
anything let alone like this futuristic
you know spaceships was crazy and
lieutenant Uhura wanted to quit the show
after the first season to go back to
Broadway which he loved and Martin
Luther King went to go visit her and
said what you're doing for the black
community is too important and you have
to you have to keep going
and so she's stuck with it for the six
seasons of original Star Trek and my
favorite part of that was because at the
time a black woman on TV is gonna be a
maid or servants are just like low-level
work Whoopi Goldberg
you know Whoopi Goldberg right famous
she saw lieutenant Uhura on TV and
called her mom like mommy mommy there's
a black woman on TV and she ain't no
mate and it inspired her to go and
become an actress mm-hmm
and so I see that in like what you're
doing and that you are yourself being a
badass
I love the Wonder Woman stuff you put it
now like I think that hippie your middle
name is like Wonder Woman and I see that
with what you're doing but also the
guest that you're bringing on to shine a
light on people that say like look this
is what's possible but how far away do
you think it is like is there just
something that is as women do you find
women are just
different or have different sets of
beliefs that are harder to overcome her
or is it just you think it's all going
to become even in 20 years would I guess
it depends on what you mean even really
for me it's about not even saying women
should be doing one thing or another
it's about just giving people permission
and I can only take it from my my spans
from growing up it's like growing up I
didn't really see that I didn't see you
know you had maybe one or two women I
mean I sleep growing up in England you
saw Margaret Thatcher you know you saw
Princess Diana really stepping into her
own but none of that actually ever felt
tangible right it was always the you
know superstars on the big screen or you
know the the really high level and then
everyone everybody else is how I felt
and so I would see the everybody else
was like well I didn't grow up in that
and that isn't my world so I can't feed
that and really what I freaking love
about social media and I know a lot of
people hate on social media but I'm
always just like the beauty that is
bought is to show the everyday person
right and I even think of myself as an
absolute everyday person I grew up in a
house in London in North London I wanted
to be in the movie industry and everyone
was like who the hell do you know in
Hollywood you know what why do you have
going to America you don't know anyone
how are you gonna get a visa it was all
this like negativity and I just was
stubborn enough to keep going and I
didn't have really anyone to model on
and I think that that's important on
what social media is doing today is that
showing that you've got these women like
Sara Blakely I mean that woman is so
freaking amazing her story of how she
you know went door to door knocking on
doors up fax machines to then literally
building a billion-dollar company like
those are the stories that I think is so
freakin motivating now to anyone
listening to you know women out there
that believe they can't it's like if you
believe you can't look at this person
look at this person look at this person
it's you know the four-minute mile all
right it's like some people just need
someone to say it's possible then to
show it's possible and then other people
are gonna step into it and that's really
what I love about the show is bringing
all different kinds of women on from you
know billionaires women that have sold
billion-dollar come
here's to you know to people who are
psychotherapists to you know just every
single woman you couldn't possibly I
just had a woman on that was from the
secret service agency okay dad's amazing
I'm looking for someone who's a
firefighter said back if anyone's
watching right now I'm looking for a
female firefighter like I'm really just
wanting to showcase women that are
making a difference and coming into
their own and the more people I can get
on the show that show that I'm really
hoping that one person's going to
resonate with someone right like Oprah
Oprah saw that one person that she
resonated with Anik quick and changed
her life and so if I can be a part of
that and bringing women on that someone
can resonate with to show oh it is
possible that that can then have that
ripple effect I always like to say like
I'm trying to throw stone in the ocean
and create a tsunami and so how do you
create that tsunami it really is you
know helping other people have a
platform to speak their story and so my
going back to your question is I'm just
hoping like I am hoping and really I'm
very optimistic that in five to ten
years that we won't be discussing is it
possible you know it's just it's just
going to be so that's my goal that you
know this discussion of why aren't there
more women in the space it's never said
again because in ten years it's just a
given I love it yeah what what else what
other kinds of people or individuals are
trying to get on the show and so yeah
really I mean I I'm I want feedback from
anyone who do you think is empowering so
when I was going through who are the
people that are incredible so I think
about the people like buckets and
categories right so you've got the
celebrities who are just doing amazing
things with their with their platform to
create attention right Selena Gomez and
things like that where there's so honest
and transparent about their struggles
and so then I think about all who are
the everyday person that aren't
necessarily told while you're impactful
but to me it's like you can't live
without these women right so
firefighters er like brain surgeon right
like you're messing with someone's
one little slip with a hand and you know
it's over but you're actually freaking
saving lives like that is so powerful to
me and I'm actually looking for so I was
I had a Secret Service agent any type of
detective like specifically serial
killers I know a lot of women killers so
there's a podcast show where it's um to
make god was it anyone that knows what
podcast I'm talking about that serial
killers throw it in the comments below
but there's two women hosts and so those
women I'd love to get on because I just
again like that they're bringing
subjects to the forefront to discuss and
when I think about just serial killers
or anything like that I'm just like I
want to know like when I'm by myself
walking down an alley I want to know
what things I need to look out for and
people that do self-defense I mean I can
keep going on and on about all the
different areas and astronauts any woman
that's just in there like really trying
to create and do something new and
unique or save lives I love it alright
took some notes help of the people
watching here and on YouTube we'll take
some notes and hit you up as well
what beat the difference for you so
you're you know you're in England you
got all these negative beliefs I can't
get a visa how I'm gonna get there I
want to I want to go to California what
didn't actually spark the shift in you
because I think that's what so many
people are missing
um so even though it has a lot of the
negativity first of all the first thing
is is that I had to understand
negativity wasn't about me it wasn't
like you're not capable and I think that
when people say things like oh it's not
possible I think it's out of their own
fear and so I had to detach myself from
what the message and then the messenger
so the message is oh it's difficult okay
well do I believe it's difficult you
know if I believe it's difficult if I
believe it's not possible then guess
what it's not gonna be possible but then
the messenger itself so hearing these
beliefs from my dad from just friends
from people at school it's like why did
they believe it's not possible is it a
reflection of them because if they
believe it's not possible it gives them
permission to say that's why I didn't
try
right that reflection thing so I was
like okay I think that there's a real
fear where if the fact that I think it's
possible is making them feel less and I
obviously don't want that but I can't
live to their their framework and then
also let's take my dad for instance the
man loves me more than life itself
and he told Tom don't marry her he told
me I was crazy marrying Tom well 19
years later I think I made the right
decision
request nutrition he was like what on
earth do you guys know about protein
bars why are you giving up the lifestyle
that you just spent the last eight years
you know developing your you know you're
risking your house so all that
negativity like is that because he
doesn't love me or is that because he
doesn't believe me
or is that a reflection of his belief
system that a women should be at home
you know nothing against him that's just
the culture he was raised in and then
also his understanding of the world so
he came from a tiny tiny village in
Cyprus and so for him it was like every
penny you can earn is a roof over your
head it's food on the table so why would
you ever risk that so I had to detach
myself from the message he was trying to
give me and then the messenger just be
empathetic to where he's coming from be
respectful to where he's coming from
because that's his point of view but to
not fall into the trap of what he says
is gospel right and what his advice is
is gospel and so that took me a long
time to separate the two but once I did
I started to really be able to lean into
what my belief system was what I think
is possible and to just keep going and
so that was a massive fundamental change
in listening to people and saying this
is how my life is versus no no I don't
have to listen to them and what do I
want my life to be and so how do you
actually make that distinction between
message and messenger because it makes
sense talking about it but it's so hard
for people to do when people are stuck
living in the world of what their
parents say and what their friends say
but you broke out and especially in the
time when it wasn't so normal to break
yeah right so how did you actually get
the awareness that
the difference so I think I am a dreamer
so that's just part of my personality so
as a dreamer growing up I was told all
these things you're gonna be a
stay-at-home wife and again nothing it
was meant to trap me it's just what I
was being told you're gonna be
stay-at-home wife as a good Greek girl
you support your husband you have the
kids you maintain the family that is
your job so I was having this info but
the dream on me was like I'm gonna win
an Academy Award and I want to you know
be in America and I love Los Angeles I
want to be part of the film industry so
I had these two competing ideas that I
would really struggle with and so I'd be
like okay first of all it started off
how can I do both right like okay yeah
so many kids and of course I want to
support my husband but of course I'm
gonna make movies then when I actually
sat down was like how do you actually do
this I just started to break it apart be
like okay well I'm still young fer made
it to America by this day and if I had
an Academy Award by this day then I
could have my children so almost like
tried to fit everything in and then just
as I was getting older as I was growing
for coming and really identifying who is
Lisa not who does everyone want Lisa to
be but Who am I actually I started to go
ham well maybe I don't want that it's
actually like can I actually question
whether I should be a stay-at-home
mother or not and then as I was asking
myself that question I was like why
can't I question it why can't I decide
to not have children and so that
question started to seep into my mind
and so when I started to say well why
can't I not have children and then I
started to play back oh I've never even
thought about this because for the last
25 30 years I've been told I'm going to
be this and so in just asking the
question helped me really get my
thoughts together so that you one thing
anyone watching right now is struggling
with someone just ask keep asking
yourself questions well why do you
believe that why is that true is that
really what you want and in the
questions come your answers you know and
one had to guess on and Cynthia Pasquale
Garcia and the one thing I freakin love
that she kept saying is I wonder ask
yourself I wonder what would happen if I
do this I wonder if I was this what that
would mean
I wonder why I'm having this feeling I'm
wonder why when that person says to me
oh you're a stay-at-home wife that it
kind of stung a bit you know like I
wonder why I'm having that feeling and
it just starts to really lay out all of
your thoughts in a non-judgmental way
because you're just answering the
question versus putting the judgment on
yourself like oh I shouldn't feel like
that so using that word wonder when in
your life did Wonder Woman become such a
integral role that's interesting thing
is I actually never even put those two
together
that's so weird um it really so here's
the thing with Wonder Woman it's not
even Wonder Woman herself that I'm like
oh my god she's so amazing it's what she
symbolizes and when I started to grow up
and see what the input is like where I'm
getting all the feedback where I'm you
know hearing about women should be it
stay at home wives or when I'm hearing
about this it's like where is it
actually coming from what is the source
that you're consuming that makes you
feel a certain way and so when I started
to recognize that the egg external
sources were my choice and that I can
mute them I can stop following people on
Instagram that don't empower me I can
stop listening to the people I can
detach myself from friends that are not
empowering me there and not encouraging
me to be the person I want and surround
myself with people that are I started to
feel like that was a frickin superpower
like that this is a tool that we all
have that we don't use and so when I
started to look at what one's a woman
and why I was gravitating towards her it
wasn't even her herself is what she
stood for right so I wear the necklace
around my neck to just remind myself
that the power is all mine right I even
say at the end of every episode of women
of impact that be the hero of your own
life and so I really believe I am the
hero of my own life
and I waited for so long to get saved to
be rescued right Disney has the whole
mythology that you're you know women
wait around for the prince to come and
rescue her and it's like I've been fed
crapped all my life I don't have to sit
here and wait for someone to come and
save me
I can freakin save myself and so for me
Wonder Woman is a symbol of that that
we shouldn't wait to be saved but we all
have the power within ourselves and so
part of my mission going you know even
beyond just the show as you know we have
a graphic novel and we're really getting
into that space I want to build so the
wish Academy which is a graphic novel
I'm putting together wish spell Wis
women of impact superheroes and I'm
doing it as an academy and I'm creating
a logo that symbolizes the academies
that everyone we can feel like that them
right even the ones women's is about a
person and I think it's important to
separate people with how you feel about
yourself and the having a symbol that
empowers you that you see your own
reflection in and so everything has kind
of been the stepping stone over
oh I've realized what one's a woman is
impactful but is that not actually her
it's what she symbolizes oh well how do
we create the symbol that everyone every
woman can own for themselves and so
that's really how everything I do is in
me asking myself these questions and
then saying well what's the answer to it
what is Lisa billion superpower the the
ability to take a punch in the face and
get back up and I don't answer it I
actually knew from other people
absolutely but I also mean from my own
failures right it's like we every single
woman I've ever interviewed has failed
at some point and it's they feared
trying and they failed by like those are
the almost the two massive keys and I
think that those are the two keys that
stop people from trying it's the fear of
failing and so if you can have the fear
but do it anyway actually posted
recently about that like sometimes the
fear is not going away so you know
you're gonna have to do it anyway that's
one thing and then the chances are you
are gonna fall on your face you are
going to take a punch to the stomach and
what do you do when that happens
and the self-soothing is like the
internal work the self-soothing of get
yourself back up you can get better this
doesn't define you this failure doesn't
make you um this failure doesn't make
you a failure right so it's detaching
it's making sure that I get back up even
when I feel
wind it even when I feel like crap
because it's not that I don't feel it
like that when I fall on my face it
freakin stinks but a lot of people I
have seen just stop there and it's like
if you can just keep going if you can
just push yourself and not let that
define who you are then magic can happen
you know I failed on an episode there
was one episode where completely failed
our audio web and I was just like okay
do I stop you know like I could have
been like what am i doing I've done like
a million different episodes and I still
failed in my audio no I just faced it
and I was like guys I've messed up oh my
god I can't believe it now move on like
let that be a lesson and so if you can
change your framework into saying a
failure can be the best freakin lesson
ever every time you fail if you keep
telling yourself that you felt oh my god
this is the best thing ever it just like
it like helps the dents and it helps the
ego get back up and so it's that that I
think has been my biggest superpower I
love it and I'm soaked with what you're
doing it's great then Congrats on having
over you crossed six figures I motive
impact and can't wait for you to get to
million and beyond all the great work
you're doing is crazy booth day time
flies when you're having fun for people
watching live or later on the YouTube
video if you want to dive more into your
world where do you want them to go yes a
please go to YouTube guys women of
impact that is definitely where I'm
putting so much of my time and energy so
go check it out if it does bring you
values shares subscribe that would be
amazing and then also on Instagram that
is where I have real-time the most fun
behind the scenes like everything is
just really what you see is what you get
amazing Lisa thank you so much
appreciate you even you know how much I
thought you did so thank you so much for
having me on
really appreciate it I love that you're
allowing your platforms that give a
voice to other women so anytime you want
to do a video compilation I got a
women that are on my show I know you're
in fact and if anyone wants to hear
women compilations from ever from women
of impact start hauling this like crazy
for something we can even we can even
both be on the intro as part of it I
mean that let's do something oh pretty
Alicia take care guys bye if you want to
see the one on one I did with Lisa's
co-founder Tom bill you check out the
video right there next to me I think
you'll enjoy it continue to believe and
I'll see you there
what are you doing you're not answering
the question I'm asking I felt so
hopeless and so lost and just unsure of
how it's gonna make anything in my life